decision charge more likely
I do everything but he's the boss he
doesn't care that's not true it's not
true it's not true I never cut corners
let me finish Christina every day I tell
him listen here it is do you want to
take cover be my guest Christina can I
talk let me finish you talk to me at
your point you know you're thinking and
you do all this stuff in front of my
customers he comes in front and he goes
she gives you know instructions to me so
and I try I try to avoid you because I
like to make yourself you know all the
time in front of me I have to say now
you're trying to say that I'm not good
for this I can go out and This Is It
I'm telling you the truth you can't
handle the truth that's what it is
going to change listening to you both
for the last five minutes I've got no
idea who's right who's wrong but how do
you survive this I don't know
does this go on at home well if you have
problems here you think you're not going
to take it home
what's this done to your relationship
what I mean he has destroyed there is no
relationship
a lawyer called me and he says here
Christina is here she's filing for a
divorce she got divorced no no we're not
whenever so you didn't sign the document
a few times did you sign it no this is
crazy what a mess yeah witness it is a
mess it's a big mess
[Music]
sometimes you have different bedrooms of
course why not
how long have you lived there almost 20
years it's all paid off
we're selling this house to save this
business and to save ourselves from
bankruptcies what what you're selling we
sold it already you've sold the house
you sold the house to put money into the
business
idea
I love the house
so I built this my house the same way
that I built this place here
[Music]
since we came here
nowhere I give no life
you know
this place destroyed our family
hi Sammy Anna Garcia from Kitchen
Nightmares how are you it's a nightmare
yes oh good can we can can we come in
and talk thank you so much thank you I
appreciate it yeah let me introduce
myself hi Anna Garcia from Kitchen
Nightmares very nice to meet you we want
to catch up with you and Sammy do you
have a few minutes for us
to talk to me I'd love to talk with you
now you talk to me and I want money
because this time from Kitchen Nightmare
I want money you want you guys did make
so much money because of us and Gordon
Ramsay tried to bury me alive or he
wants I will bury him first I will bury
him person bury your kitchen nightmare
also because you did it on purpose you
set me up and this is what you did you
try to bury us alive alive and you
didn't do it and I wouldn't let nobody
to do it well will you sit down and talk
with us Sammy about what happened and
everything that's happened to [__]
himself because he was not fair he was
not fair how was he
because he shouldn't represent us that
way I'm going to go against Fox against
Gordon Ramsay kitchen nightmare let me
show you something it's disgusting so I
posted I took the screen Sammy who is he
he has no balls he's jealous of my balls
this is what he is we were made to look
like the most psychotic lunatic people
in the universe and after watching
Kitchen Nightmares I see all the crazy
but I don't see any of the good I know
the people that came here were yelpers
because I have proof of it they were on
Yelp talking about it after they were
filming and before they were coming here
this is not stuff that I've invented I'm
not delusional I'm not crazy yes we are
passionate yes we are wild if I came
after you you would probably stand up
too if I came after anybody else you
would defend yourself wouldn't you if
you have a family wouldn't you defend it
has it been stressful stressful yes it's
been very stressful we've had people
walk through my doors come casually over
here like this walk over look at the
display case keep going like this and
then leave and then my waitress comes up
to me now we have waitresses because we
had to change our whole procedure
because the whole universe thought my
husband was stealing the tips so we
tried something new I took all of the
negative things that Gordon Ramsay said
and I tried to improve on it that's why
I had him come here people come here to
try to set us up because they think it's
funny because they have a hard on for
Gordon Ramsay there was one person he
left on this plate and I have it in my
office and I have the surveillance
camera proof of it he puts a giant
rubber cockroach on the plate and left
it there left without buying a cake and
thought that that was funny we are
dealing with that daily it's not going
to work here we stood up to Gordon
Ramsay we're going to stand up to the
world because we don't go down without a
fight we have to show the world in every
single business owner out there that you
have to stand up you cannot let anyone
Shake You Down we have a voice he has a
voice and it's up to us to stay strong
and to show our true product and what we
really have to offer here and his big
company
I'm not nervous for several energy to
taste my food
well let's put it this way
he's going to go to heaven today
how is it the meatball sandwich the
meatballs I've ever had that it's cat
food oh [__] ready yeah I want to know
where the [__] you were eating cat food
long story holy [__]
[Music]
yes what is that behind your head that's
a hologram freaking me out you know what
a lot of people are afraid about that's
a clown
oh gosh how long has that been up there
oh probably about 15 years is that whose
idea was that that's food that's mine oh
my God
how's it going
really
blood's done get it up no it's not I
just checked it it's not it's done this
is [__] check it like two seconds ago
get it out
that's pretty bad it's disgusting that's
disgusting shut up yeah
perfect let's go
Chef's calzone
Jesus
do I look like one of the Denver Broncos
that I can eat this thing it looks huge
thank you Don
[Music]
ate what he's doing these portions I
mean they're hideous how much filling
has he put in there
raw onion
Paulette yes
how is she putting in there look all
that pepperoni I mean the slices of
sauce Jam together yeah I've never seen
a calzone so full I mean the feeling's
cold that is hideous I don't like that
either I've been wanting to take that
calzone and fling it like a Frisbee for
about 20 euros Keith I got some
critiques for you
are you kidding me listen to me damn it
the complaint is it's so full it's cold
shut up it's gonna be a wake-up call for
Pete
I put my pizza up against anybody in the
country
Denver Colorado in a country that's how
confident I am about my pizza let's go
come on
okay here we go here's your sausage
pizza
holy isn't that ridiculous
it's like the pizza there's eight Denver
yeah
[__] okay I'll let you take that here
thank you
[Music]
oh my God
the oil the grease coming out of there
the oil in there look at the grease is
he said it's too greasy just exactly
what I I feel I don't I don't want to
hear
[Music]
Pizza in Denver I mean does that look
like the best pizza trust me I can tell
you it doesn't taste good Celestia the
dough is so thick why I mean it's just
like a loaf of bread it's like a
baguette in there that's our thin crust
that's the thin crust
stop
wow seriously a lot of people get upset
with me for that when they ask for the
thin crust and I bring them with them
wow did you touch that those raw oh wow
it is raw pastry oh my God what a mess
darling I'm done alrighty I addressed it
okay I'll let him know messy
that is definitely not the best pizza in
Denver let's get that right and wow
Italian [__] flies
[Music]
flies everywhere where they're coming
from
that fly won't leave you alone
ah anyway
shall I order okay all right let's go
for the New Orleans barbecue shrimp
thank you okay uh the Yucatan sea
scallops okay and is there a salmon
special today the salmon special today
is baked with a dill Dijon cream sauce
okay yeah let's go for that as well I
think we're done for now we'll turn
those into Alexa thank you
[Music]
orders in we bring it on
how are you my name is Wiley why did you
say oh the sun the sun yeah okay great
how long you been here I've been here
about 10 years what do you think the big
problem the Russian is I think the big
problem is the the decor have you ever
tried to take some of this junk down or
I'm afraid to I'm afraid of it my father
might do if I trade to take something
down yeah if he's kept it up here for 30
years but is it worth anything I doubt
it it's like a garage sale that you're
staring at eating it oh yeah well good
to me but definitely thank you it's
great to meet you bye-wise good to see
you too
here's your barbecue shrimp all right
my dishes are excellent and if Chef
Ramsay doesn't like any of my cooking it
will piss me off oh this is barbecue
shrimp barbecue shrimp
it's a very strange looking barbecue
sauce it's a cream barbecue cream sauce
barbecue cream sauce look at the color
of that is that is it is a shrimp
barbecue or is it the sauce that's
barbecued it's the barbecue sauce oh see
and why would you sort of coat the lemon
and cream it's a collateral damage yeah
I'll say thank you you're welcome
[Music]
[__] me
I wouldn't feed that to the [__]
mannequin even she'd manage to throw
that up
that sauce is hideous and the shrimp was
tough as old booze and the Flies are
landing on me as opposed to on the
shrimp
the look on your face doesn't look good
no
it's a really weird texture on a flight
bypasses the [__] dish you know is
bad trust me um I'm done with that thank
you
thanks Tommy jeez
[Music]
so what do you say about those
um it has a weird texture to the sauce
he doesn't know why it would be called
barbecue
people have been coming here for 33
years the food cannot be that bad
[Music]
oh this is your
sister still Dijon cream so somebody
likes cream in the kitchen is that why
all these cream sauces come from I don't
know who originally started them but
Alexa cooks with a lot of cream wow
everything's made with heavy cream
we have oh there's a salmon under there
it's a cream sauce
thank you
someone turns Frozen doesn't taste fresh
at all it's dry very dry wow I mean it's
very old school cream on cream on cream
but thank you for darling you're very
welcome yeah that wasn't pleasant all
right I'll let them know
that was hideous he says the salmon
tastes dry what come on really he said
CREAM again yeah well everything he
ordered has cream but I know wow I would
think people would know what they're
ordering before they did it but that's
whatever I think everything is delicious
I wouldn't serve it if I didn't think it
was delicious there goes another one
foreign